[Music]
and have you seen this Matthew Matthew
Lawrence all cupped up with girlfriend
Chili from TLC well this morning he sort
of broke a little baby news exclusively
with our Deidre Behar do you feel like
that's in the cards for you in the near
future I hope that's the game plan yeah
I know that's what we're trying to do
[Music]
my life is is in complete Bloom right
now I get to spend time with the amazing
woman like chili I've never gotten to be
able to experience that kind of a
relationship before she's really really
special
[Music]
didn't you guys like wind up on the same
plane or something oh yes you're right
okay so that sounds like there was this
big snowstorm I'd be back for work so I
was getting them to change my flights
all around so really it was the flight
talking and then afterwards saying hey
you know what let's keep in contact and
it almost did not happen I mean
literally an hour before the flight took
off they were like okay we got you on
the slide you gotta go
life kind of got shaken up a little bit
last year he tested me you know and um
and I learned so much about myself and
I'm so thankful and blessed for the
opportunity to grow and that's really
what came out of it I wound up getting
involved with people that
I was trying to please never freaking
Works Matthew Joey and Andy put it all
out there on brotherly love their
podcast is named after the Lawrence's
90s show where E.T saw their tight Bond
they're the best
that was why I was so excited about this
podcast is because it was an excuse for
me to sit around a table Yeah and talk
to my brothers and get to hang out with
them
and the fam's expanding Joey married
third wife Samantha last May and
welcomed his third daughter Dylan in
January I was quite Young when I had my
first you know daughter you know now 46.
the Knights of like passing out and
waking up going I literally don't
remember the last 10 hours what a great
night's sleep I literally haven't had
that since 2006.
[Music]